O ne o
[Müzik]
abone ol
e Herkese merhaba
12 bir şey hazırlamışsın hazırlığım yok
galiba dedi Öyle oldu aslana konuşacağım
istedim söylüyor
şöyle
gerçekten Hayatta hiçbir şeyin benim
için ön hazırlığını yapmak verilmiş ve
yaramadığı hiçbir şey çok önemli
hazırlamadım çok plan yapmadım Güler
yaparsam tutmaz gibi bir problem oluyor
o yüzden de bu ya da çıkarken iki tane
sevmedim bir heyecanla dedim Burası
benim Sizinle konuşmam da
[Müzik]
ne
anlatacak olursam Aslında benim adımın
içinde çok fazla çare var Geçen hafta
yeni başka bir sahne Evet beş dakika
umut etmek üzerine
konuşmuştuk Umut etmenin Aslında çok
değerli bir şey olduğunu öğrendim
hayatında Çünkü ben 1984 Ağrı doğum
gününde doğru ürün sabahta Saat beş
buçukta
duruyor dönemin ölümüyle benim doğumun
gerçekleştiği da
[Müzik]
Ne
yaparsınız falan diyorum gerçekten hayat
biraz böyle birşey hepimiz aynı tam
Vallahi aynı yerlerde aynı şartlara
sahip olarak doğruyoruz ama hepimizin
Bence doğru itibariyle sunulmuş
imkanları var bunu birim dinlemek
keşfedip getirmek tamamen size kalmış
bir şey ben kendi halini keşfettim
Aslında
doğduğumda gerçekten elektrik yoktu Bir
önceki konuşmamızda söylemiştim yine
söyleyeceğim doğduğum köyde elektrik
yoktu ve ben 7 yaşında falan da 6'ya
yedi yaşındaydı köy elektrik çekiyorlar
bir kuzenim var insan için
gittik haberler
dokunduğum şeye açtın mı
[Müzik]
Selam
bugün baktığımız yerde işte anlamı de
onların da sosyal sorumluluk projesi
YouTube mascolo dün aldım yani 37 yıl
gibi 38 yıl vereyim artık ama 37 38 20
gibi bir sürede sanki böyle gerçekten
araştırma yaparken
nasıl bugüne kadar geldiğini görüyorum o
[Müzik]
O
çok güzel
baba ile anne ben çok güzel yemekler
yapılır doğal olarak kalan hemşire
olarak şey sevgisi dolmaya başladı beyaz
şeker hastalığı benim tanıdığım bir
hastalık ve gerçekten
hastası olduğunu düşünüyorum o
[Müzik]
de
geliyorum İstanbul'a
İstanbul'a geldim annemler babamlar
98 yılında Antalya'ya taşıdılar 2-3 sene
Orada kalıp Sonra İstanbul'a geldiğimde
2000'li geçirmiştir bir çok
geliştiriyorum Evet gerçekten
yazıyorum
sevgisi bendee doğuda dinlerler
yerleştirdik diye bir gelenek var
geliştirmişler bugüne kadar getirmişler
Aslında beri Hem kitap okumaya olmadı bu
İstanbul'a geldi ve İstanbul'da ilk 11i
bu
sonra hayatıma girdi
eğitimi aldım oluyoruz kısa geçeceğim
ama
yani işte eğitimi almak ya da iyi bir
okuldan mezun olmak falan çok
hayatınızda sadece ulaşabilirsiniz
hayatın içinden ya kapıdan şekilde
biliyor musunuz içeri girdiğinizde o
[Müzik]
bu birşey oldu Üstüne de işte Türkiye'de
fişeklerle bundan sonra bir şeyler önce
almaya gittim onu aldım staj Yaptım daha
doğrusu sormuş nereye geldim
üstünde de çeşitli Çalışmaya başladın mı
[Müzik]
Bu çok güzel bir şey
2017 yılının sonlarına doğru da
Türkiye'deki için mezhep projesine kendi
alanında ilk modern projesi
gerçekleştirdi ve sonra tekrar o
[Müzik]
bu geçiyor ateşli keşfedildi Gün
itibariyle sana bağlı kullanmıştır
abone ol
ama
bir şartım muhabbetin baharat çıkması
vuracağım dedim olur
dedim nasıl olacak bu işler anlatımlı
olacağımızı yer alacağı nasıl bir şey
olacak Evet tabii ki hayatımda ilk defa
kendimi olmak istiyorum yapmak istiyorum
Yani bu
bir şey mı
o
bizden 2017 yılında Türkiye'ye tek
baharatı parasını koyduk ama o Kazan
dolusu unutmasın da bir sandık dolusu
vardı Ben önce dünyada Türkiye'de
Gittiğin her yerde bulduğum bütün
baharatları elde
çatısındaki bir
lokanta yapacağız
[Müzik]
o
Türkiye'nin ilk baharat Kütüphanesi
Onunla beraber Muhammed Elmas kurduk
262 368 baharat bulduk Tabii ki bunlar
aromatik bitkiler diğerleri
Gerçekten mi
bu
üniversitelerin bilim ile çalışır
dönüştürmemiz
Fatma çok gibiyim işte onlardan destek
aldım Şimdi Antep'ten ikinci parasını
İstanbul Üniversitesi bazı şeyler var
bizim ile beraber hep biz Türkiye'de
gerçekten şey yapıyoruz yani bir İpek
pul biberi aldığınızda büyüme kürlerini
bir numarası olacak yani kaç numara
aldığınız bir alıyorsun bugün videosu
Yarın bir aldım almaya gidiyorsun başka
bir şey olursa hiçbir şey oluyor bu da
karıştırmak Aslında biz daha vurgulamak
adına bir şey yapıyoruz Ben de
Beach buraya konuşmayı istediğimi
söylediğimde aslında kendi adıma alayım
dedim ki ya buhar
anlatmalıyız Türkiye'de çok önemli bir
sorun üstünde bir cr1t
bu
dizlerindeki adımlar
Biz oralardan gelen buradan diye yani
buradan olduğunu tespit ettiği baharatı
kendimiz Keşke demişiz diye böyle
ile ilgili Ama bu ne
ne anlatmak üzere bir proje Bu da bugün
burada olmamızı sağlayan şey baharatlı
benim arada buraya getirdi bunu
bilmiyorum şu Farkediyorum gördüğümde
Umut etmenin insan inanması gerekir
inanmalı ne kadar önemli bir şey
olduğunu biliyorsanız gerçekten bazı
insanlarda şey demiyorlar geçmişten
günümüze baktığımızda her milletin her
topluluğun inandığı şeyler var ama ben
kendi değerlerine kendi çöplerini sahip
çıkan bu ne an kendi içi yaratıcılığına
bir şeyleri yapabileceğini o
bu için üç nokta arasındaki farkı
baktığımızda temiz dönüyorsa eşit doğru
uzak o zaman hepimizin her şeyi yapmak
lazım var ben sonra
2019'da otelden ayrıldım ayrıldım proje
yaptık
kuruldu onunla ilgili dünyanın her
yerinden çıktı ama o
da
gitti Belediyeye gittim
yapıyorsunuz yani önce
sormaktır yanlış yere bakmışsın
gerçekten yani olmaz dediler Ben bunun
üstüne oradan
var dedi artık yani
açıyoruz tamamen yapıyoruz ve dürüst
atıyoruz Ben dedim ki böyle Mutfağı o
üstüne ben de
ve kuzenim arkadaşların tanıdıkların
sinir etmek gibi bir sürü biz aldık sen
salakmısın mesaj atmıyorsun yanında
ayran çalışacaksın Ama en çok tatlı
olmuş böyle bir dönem
sonra bir şey söyleyeceğim yani
Bitmesin 33 milyon TL'ye
ve sadece o
[Müzik]
da herhangi bir şey yok Merhaba bakıyor
işte bir ara sokakta hiç bir şekilde
ediyoruz arası alıyoruz ama ben
inanıyorum inanma lan bütün takımları
sonsuz açtığını hayatım boyunca inandı
ve inandıkça da bunu başka bir yere
varacağını da inanıyorum şimdi
galataport'ta bu sene getiriyoruz
dükkan
dükkan o ayran reçetesini oldu babamın
yardımı ile
[Müzik]
16.02 yetebilir çalışarak Tabii ki ağzım
başka şeylerden vazgeçerek bazı sevgilin
olmaz bazı başka bir şey olur ama bu
şeylerden vazgeçmek uğruna bile olsa onu
testlerinin çok geri dönüşü olmayan
büyük bir şey olduğunu çok iyi
karşılaştığını ve her şeyden önce insan
hayatında sonsuz bir dönüştüğünü gördüm
hepinize mutlu çok mutlu bilmez
[Alkış]